welcome to the first David Pakman show
during the regime of President Donald
Trump the era of the orange president in
chief has begun and it began with a
truly bizarre speech among one of the
most poorly attended inaugurations in a
long time followed by the biggest
protests in American history which we
will get to we will get to all of it so
I'm glad you're with us today Trump
seemed genuinely bored annoyed and and
just sort of uninterested during the
entire inauguration I got a pretty
sinister vibe from the entire Trump clan
sitting up there sort of a dark energy
and an absolutely ludicrous inauguration
speech that many trumpets thought were
great I had people tweeting me Pat about
how wonderful the speech was it's a
beginning to the return of American
greatness etc I found it to be
nationalistic but in a way that was just
sort of feeling around in the dark for
some kind of very concocted pseudo
patriotism and really devoid of any
meaning
I really just found it to be a genuinely
poor speech I mean it was maybe 15
minutes long at the most it sounded like
he may have been able to write that
himself yeah usually during inauguration
speeches there's this appeal so the
people who didn't vote for you right of
acknowledging your place in history he
didn't do any of that none of it and you
we talked last week about how hard it
hard to believe it was that Trump was
writing the speech himself after hearing
it I think it's actually possible I
don't know if you've noticed that Trump
seems incapable of complex sentence
structure you know President Obama would
be asked a question you would say let me
say a couple of things he was asked
about guns he would first debunk the
idea that he's gonna grab and then use
an analogy comparing seatbelts and the
auto industry and reduction in fatality
rates real explanations Trump on the
other hand is president me verb noun is
the way that I'm calling it right I make
America great again I repeal Obamacare I
build wall make America great again he
speaks in a way that could only appeal
to someone who is incredibly
unsophisticated and if you take the
speech verbatim too he promised to
eliminate crime game writing disease and
and giving this vaguely nationalistic
and bizarre
the written speech Trump chose multiple
times to repeat an anti-semitic slogan
that he was specifically asked not to
use by the anti-defamation league it's
called America first to talk about
foreign policy this is a slogan that was
used by people who were warning before
the u.s. got into World War two that
Jewish interests Jewish Americans were
pushing the u.s. to enter the war
because of their own interests coming
ahead of America's interests and the
idea of America first was to sort of
fight back against quote Jewish trickery
to pull us into World War two and the
crowd went wild every time Donald Trump
used the slogan the small crowd actually
liked it take a look at this we
assembled here today are issuing a new
decree to be heard in every city in
every foreign capital and in every Hall
of power from this day forward a new
vision will govern our land from this
day forward it's going to be only
America first America first
and I get that many people might see
this as no big thing but if you're not
familiar with the history of this this
is significant it involves Nazi
sympathizer Charles Lindbergh it plays
significantly into anti anti-semitic
history and this is not about Trump
being anti-semitic specifically I know
his daughter converted to Judaism
because his son is Longy as son as
son-in-law is Jewish et cetera but this
is about who it resonates with and we're
actually going to be interviewing all
right white separatist leader Richard
Spencer and alasc him about whether he
likes this stuff but it certainly is
arousing the white supremacists that
loved Trump David Duke for example
actually sent out a tweet where he said
dr. David Duke Trump inauguration speech
declares war on the neo cons and
promotes our slogan America first maybe
since Trump doesn't read anything he
actually thinks that America first is
something new that he came up with the
real slogan of the Trump administration
is gonna be the same one as of the Trump
campaign and as the Trump transition
team which is we're feeling around in
the dark to see how we can possibly make
it another day and they've certainly
made it another day and they're going to
be around that and again I don't think
Donald Trump is anti-semitic I don't
think there's any reason to believe that
but this is some time for perspective
here this is the presidential
inauguration no doubt about it and
perspective completely missing from the
entire proceedings over the weekend